Oh
Oh
you
in chapter 6 of Leviathan Hobbes appears
to be going off into a different
direction he's talking about what we
would nowadays typically associate with
psychology and say well that's really
got nothing to do with any of the other
things that he's focused on with you
know political science or with
epistemology or neck even necessarily
metaphysics psychology is about the the
emotions of the human being their
feelings what he's calling the passions
their fundamental motivations remember
though that psychology is a discipline
that originally emerged from philosophy
and at the time that Hobbes is writing
it's not yet an independent discipline
that's going to happen several centuries
later so Hobbs as a good philosopher
trying to make sense of the entire human
being and really have of the world as
much as he can is going to be doing some
psychology now he's talking about
voluntary emotions will get to wise
calling them voluntary in a moment I
want to focus here on this this notion
of the passions Hobbs is like many of
his other contemporaries in trying to
figure out how our emotional life our
effective life our motivations really
work in part because they're often tends
to be as we see this early on even with
playdough a dissonance between what our
emotions or our appetites or our desires
are telling us to do and what reason or
rationality or prudence is telling us to
do and Hobbes is not going to talk about
the passions of the soul because he
doesn't actually believe in anything
like a soul but he is going to talk
about the human mind the human mind is
just as much a matter of passions as it
is of thoughts as a matter of fact you
might say that passions are a kind of
thought just as much as about sense
issues just as much about reasoning this
really is what drives us this is what
gets us moving this is what brings us to
do things and this is what motivates
must
much of our reasoning so we really want
to have a good sense about what's going
on with this he has this term called
endeavor and endeavor he views and
something physical as a matter of fact
all these things are ultimately going to
be physical so he says in animals
there's two sorts of motions peculiar to
them one called vital which has begun
during generation and continue without
interruption throughout their whole life
like you know circulation of the blood
breathing you know nutrition excretion
all those sorts of things that we don't
really see as voluntary they just happen
right there physical processes but their
physical processes that living tissues
have to have in order to remain living
tissues others are voluntary motions and
he gives examples like to go to speak to
move any of our limbs in such manner as
is first fancied in our minds so are you
might say our conscious life our life
that has to do with what we choose on
some level to do is going to be
motivated by what he calls endeavor so
endeavor is the broadest designation for
this this emotional or effective
dimension of human life he says you know
although unstudied men do not conceive
any motion at all to be there when the
thing moved is invisible that does not
hinder but that such motions are and
there are small beginnings of motion
within the body of the human being
before they appear in walking speaking
striking and all the other visible
actions and this he calls endeavour so
this is the beginning of our our
conscious actions like moving a hand or
approaching the camera or you know
putting chalk up to my cheek or any of
those sorts of things taking my glasses
off taking about putting my glasses back
on taking them off again all those are
voluntary actions but they begin with
endeavor and endeavor comes you might
say in two main flavors or if you like
polarities and here you're going to see
that Hobbes is saying things very
similar to some other thinkers that
we've looked at in the past
there is appetite or desire and that's
motion towards something i want to write
on the chalkboard i am drawn towards the
truck board i'm attracted to it right i
turn my body towards it I focus my
attention on it you actually want to
hear what I have to say you don't mute
the volume you listen to what I say put
your headphones on so that you can get
rid of the other distractions you're
watching the board now that's motion
towards right appetite or desire then
there's motion away from this is the
opposite of desire what he calls a
version and you know this is a common
term for that so we have a push and we
have a pole you might say we have a
positive and we have a negative motion
away from things is a version when we
are averse to something we don't want
that thing so he says this endeavor when
it's towards something which causes it
is called the appetizer desire this
latter being the general name and often
times restrain to signify the desire of
food namely hunger and thirst when
endeavour is from word something that's
a beautiful English word that is using
from word is generally called aversion
since we got these from the Latins they
had other words from the Greeks doesn't
matter what we call them we can call
them you know fort and I you know and
the old German Freudian thing or we can
say being drawn towards or being
repelled by we have a whole vocabulary
for this sort of thing the main thing to
understand is that these are basic human
drives these are basic human experiences
and they're going on all the time within
every human being how do we get to this
other stuff so we have appetite or
desire we have a version he says that
much men desire they were also said to
love love the feeling that we feel in
its very broad sense he doesn't mean
romantic love he doesn't mean you know
mother love or something like that he
means this
very encompass same thing and Heath he
doesn't necessarily have to mean you
know like hating somebody's guts
terribly you can say I hate chocolate
would be a strange thing to say that
there are some people who do right or I
love chocolate those are those are
things that we can say and he points out
that how can we distinguish it love and
hate are really expressions of aversion
and desire but when we talk about having
desire for something what we mean is
we're talking about something in its
absence or when we don't yet have it
right and when we feel an aversion
towards something again you know it may
not be totally absent but because it is
pushing us away but it is not quite yet
there and then when it's there we hate
it I hate when it rings on me when I'm
wearing my my corduroy because my
corduroy gets wet and it doesn't dry out
for a long time you know we say things
like this in an ordinary life I hate
that guy why does he have to ride the
same bus as me he's always playing his
music so so loud you're averse to that
before he gets on the bus as he's
walking out of the bus he like oh man
that guy again oh you reverse to him and
then when he's sitting next to you Hobbs
and say well you hate him you know
somebody else gets on the bus the guy
who always brings cotton candy out and
he always brings enough for everybody I
do you love that guy right you see him
walking down the street like I hope he
catches the boss oh good he's on now you
you know you feel that sense of love
towards it and when you're imagining him
as present you feel loved and when
you're imagining the other guy as
present you feel you feel hatred towards
them these are feelings that we feel we
can also talk about another sort of
example or expression of this polarity
things that we love things that we feel
desire for when we're actually enjoying
them we feel what Hobbes calls delight
or pleasure you know if you know writing
on the truck
board is what I really get into Oh may
have this is so good yeah I'm feeling
pleasure now feeling you know delight
I'm not really because because you don't
well I'll tell you what would I feel
towards chalk in a moment it's that it's
that displeasure by the way hobbs also
says to when we're talking about mental
pleasure we we talk about joy so you
know I've used the dating example in one
of the other videos you remember when
you go on your first date with somebody
who you're really attracted to and you
know holy you know whatever you want to
say they're attracted to you to remember
how wonderful that feels that's not just
a physical pleasure in the sense of you
know you know your your body feeling a
certain way you might actually feel your
body my feeling you know that that you
might be throwing up the next moment
could you have those butterflies in your
stomach but psychologically you feel a
sense of well-being of happiness of joy
that's that now you know on the other
side things that we are averse to things
that we hate when we have when we're
stuck with them we feel displeasure or
we feel pain that guy gets on the bus
with its stupid music that's just
thumping the whole time I wish you would
shut up and get out of here by the way
he also stinks you know it'd be nice if
the guy took a shower once in a while
you know we can go on and on and on
those are modes of displeasure you know
it can be stretching it a little bit to
talk about pain because you know we
typically associate pain with like in a
physical pain but in the broad sense
pain is anything that that bothers us
when we're thinking about mental things
we can talk about grief you know the the
deprivation of things that we we really
care about you know when somebody dies
for example why do we feel grief because
a good something that we actually
delighted in something that we love
something that we wanted has been taken
away and we reverse to them you know
sometimes you can take these and flip
them around now i mentioned that i would
say something else about chalk and I
not going to talk about chalk per se
what I'm going to say is you know when
it comes down to it you can say dr.
Sandler how do you feel about cha do you
have an appetite towards it or do you
have an aversion to it do you love it or
do you hate it you know does it give you
a joy to contemplate chalk or does it on
the other hand give you grief and I can
say we have a great word for these days
yeah now what is that as we write it
these days Matt well that's what Hans
calls context and contempt goes along
with love and hate we don't always love
or hate things he says those things
which we neither desired nor hate were
said to contend contempt being nothing
else but an in mobility or kumta maseeh
of the heart in resisting the action of
certain things and proceeding from that
the heart has already moved otherwise by
more potent objects or from want of
experience with them so you know why
don't I care about Chuck I suppose if
truck was the only thing in the world
maybe i would feel love or hate towards
it but it's pretty low on on the level
of you know things that matter to me now
if you if you take the chalking I'm not
going to do this because it really
creeps me out when people do the truck
in the scraping sound on the chalkboard
and I don't like that that I actually
feel this pleasure about but chalk in
general and I feel contempt at that
right I don't really care about it one
way or the other this is going to assume
a very important role in some of the
other emotions and in human relations as
we move into some of the other chapters
so Hobbs goes on and he says that you
know this motion that we that's called
appetite seems to be a corroboration of
vital Motion to help their own to such
things that are called the light you
know I have certain names and we have we
have pleasure
with them and then he goes out and says
these simple passions called appetite
desire love a version hate joy grief and
also you should have added in their
contempt have their names for diverse
considerations diversified now what does
that mean I have to do a little bit of a
racer here for diverse considerations
diversified the wonderful wine isn't it
what he's saying there is that these
basic emotions and I understand that if
some of you are in psychology you may
say he's left out some some basic
emotions because you're working with a
different set of them that we use in
other psychological theories but he got
to go with hobbes a little bit on this
just to see where he's he's actually
heading he is going to say that doesn't
race very well does it he is going to
say that we can take these and basic
emotions or passions and we can do four
things with them the first is that we
can we can modify them in terms of the
what he calls the opinion of likelihood
of achieving
now why does that matter well when we're
feeling desire for something we want to
achieve something we want to get
something we want to enjoy something
when we're feeling a version we want
something not to be there we want to get
away from it we want to escape it and we
can focus on how likely how probable it
is that we're going to get what we want
or not get what we don't want but it
matters not just what the actual
likelihood is but what we take that
likelihood to be so some of the early
examples that he gives appetite with an
opinion of attaining is called hope when
we feel hope we are feeling desired
toward something and at the same time we
have a positive opinion of the
likelihood of getting it because when we
don't have that when we have an appetite
for something but we don't have that
opinion we think we're not going to get
it we feel despair so you see other
emotions can be produced by changing
this variable here he goes on he says a
version with opinion of hurt from the
object you think you're going to
actually get it hurt by it fear the same
with a hope of avoiding that hurt by
resistance courage so we can we can
bring up all sorts of new considerations
that produce additional passions going
down this road is going to gradually
reveal to us all these different
emotions that the human being can feel
what's another way that we can produce a
new emotion he says from the project
that is love or hate or you can even say
felt contempt towards so he's got some
examples here desire of good to another
is benevolence feeling you know goodwill
towards another person if to man
generally good nature desire of riches
covetousness or green desirable officer
precedence ambition these are you might
say emotions or drives or hobbes gonna
use this word passions and they depend
on the object now it doesn't just have
to be love or hate because contempt can
also fit in there as well contempt of
little helps and hindrances is what he
calls magnanimity and magnanimity in
danger of death or wounds is what we
call valor or fortitude magnum entity
and the use of riches liberality we can
go on and on and on you see that we can
derive a number of different passions a
number of different emotions a number of
different drives by changing the object
that law or hate or contempt applies to
and then we can compounded even further
we can go on there's another way he says
consideration of the passions together
we can combine them so you know one
example of this would be love you says
love of one singularly with desire to be
singularly beloved so there we're
talking about the object right the
passion of love the same with fear that
the love is not mutual jealousy what is
jealousy it's actually a combination of
two different emotions coming together
love and a particular can of fear that's
what produces jealousy so some emotions
are actually going to be composite
they're going to be more complex they're
going to be combinations of others let
me see if I have some some other ones
here for example grief for the calamity
of another is pity and arises from the
imagination that the light calamity may
befall himself and therefore is also
called compassion so you know you see
somebody else suffering something and
you feel bad about that because you're
averse to it and at the same time you
fear that that can happen to you because
they're similar to you that's a pity or
compassion is so that's a competent
motion as well then we finally have one
other one which is one other possibility
which is the alteration or succession
when one emotion one passion one drive
changes into another or one follows
another what would be some examples of
that in these that he gives he's got
this sudden glory and sudden dejection
those are our cases where something has
changed very quickly those quads
laughing and crying right he says sudden
dejection is caused by accidents has
suddenly take away some some hope or
prop of their power so you know I first
we're feeling confident we're feeling
hopeful about getting what it is that we
want and then somebody comes along and
says no you're not getting it and then
we feel bad and now we cry that's an
example of another complex emotion so
sudden dejection the kind of thing that
makes us cry laughter is another example
of
that is well for husk you notice that
he's got a whole bunch of different
examples here I mean we could run down
the whole list here of things he has
despair fear courage anger hope
confidence diffidence benevolence
covetousness ambition cowardice or
pusillanimous magnanimity fortitude
liberality wretchedness kindness natural
lust luxury the passion of love jealousy
revenge fulness curiosity where you just
keep going on and on and on Hobbs is
trying to from this basis of you know
certain emotions and these ways of
combining them together or modifying
them get us the entire range of human
emotional and effective life he's trying
to provide us with a mechanistic account
of that there's one other thing that we
do need to discuss in this part so that
we didn't get to now we want to focus on
the part about the voluntary so what
does it mean for something to be
voluntary oftentimes we'll say something
is voluntary when we indeed choses so my
erasing this chalkboard is a voluntary
motion because I am choosing to erase it
other times we'll talk about the
voluntary as encompassing even things
that we didn't do but we could have done
because we were responsible for it Hobbs
is it going to go a little bit further
than that he is willing to say that what
we do as human beings is we have all
these
right and these passions are this
complicated interaction and there's
sometimes going in different directions
but they ultimately lead us to something
whatever you know we add them up maybe
you feel anger and fear at the same time
you know like when when somebody insults
you and you think I should you know I
should go take revenge on that person I
should say something in response but
you're also afraid of what might happen
you have several different passions that
are that are fighting within you and you
might engage in deliberation you might
actually ask yourself well should I do
this or should I do that you might think
to yourself about Hobbes talks about
that he says when in the mind of man
appetites and aversions hopes and fears
concerning one of the same thing arise
alternately and diverse good and evil
consequences of the doing or emitting of
the thing propounded come successively
in our thoughts so sometimes we have an
appetite to it sometimes an aversion
sometimes hope to be able to do it
sometimes the spear of fear to attempt
it the wholesome of desires aversions
hopes and fears continue until the thing
be either done or thought impossible
that's what we call the liberation so
the liberation is the sum of the
captions that we feel about something
and then we eventually come to the point
where we say I'm going to do this or I'm
not going to do it or maybe I'll wait
until later and then decide right so he
says this happens with human beings and
this also happens with animals
deliberation ends when that where of
they deliberate is either daughter
thought impossible until then we're free
to decide to do it or not to do it even
though we're being motivated by our
passions and then we arrive at a point
where we either act or don't
if we think it's possible and we want to
do something we do it if we think it's
impossible then we don't do it so he
says in deliberation the last appetite
or aversion immediately adhering to the
action is that which we call the will we
get the word voluntary from the latin
word for will voluntas voluntary action
concerns the will but the will for
Hobbes is essentially just the product
of all these passions all these drives
all these being pushed and pulled and
drawn and repulsed in all these
different modalities that's what the
will is he that says it doesn't even you
don't even really need to think about
freedom of the will or anything like
that you're free until you actually
decide and then of course you've decided
so it doesn't matter but so long as
there's sort of a play of the appetites
or desires or versions with each other
you are free you are responsible it's
your will so the passions produce
volunteer emotions as a matter of fact
in a certain way even the passions
themselves can be to some extent
volunteer emotions do you have any of
any responsibility and how angry you get
or how sad you get or you know whether
you desire things too much do you have
any role in being able to change that
Homs would say that that makes it
voluntary so what we've got here sort of
sum up is a picture of the human being
as again still a machine but now driven
by all these different desires and
aversions that are part of our nature or
that we learn over time and they produce
or keep us from produce
our actions deliberation and the will
fit into this but they're largely a
product and a some of our passions